don't do drugs
but i was doing
i don't think we got that yeah
but when i was in high school when the
first times i got high i was at a
friend's house we smoked weed in
her car and then went into her house and
we made popcorn so we put popcorn in the
microwave yes and then left and we went
to watch uh nickelodeon guts
aggro crab aggro crab yeah we watched a
full episode of guts on cable and then
we were like i wonder if the popcorn's
done
a half hour later
so we walk into the kitchen and the
microwave's still on
somehow you found the button on the
microwave that's just go yeah
just go go
never stop
so we hit stop after hitting never stop
and
um
and you know how like smoke rises
it's like science scientifically smoke
rises yeah that's a fact smoke goes nuts
goes up uh we opened the microwave
and uh
black smoke came out of the microwave
but cascaded down
like a waterfall of black smoke like
landed on the stove and onto the onto
the floor and i
uh ran home
to this day don't know
what happened
like the first season of loss they're
just i would make a smoke yeah
that that's really that explains that
whole series this one got high and made
popcorn right
and then here we are that should have
that would have been a better ending to
that series